you moved to LA 12 years ago from where
I moved to LA Oh No when I was 12 but
when you were 12 I brought two from New
Jersey and I didn't I don't know like I
loved the show nah no to a no the first
one I mean the second one I'm sure it's
good but I'm a little older now so I
don't really watch it but and so I would
watch the first one with like Luke Perry
and I love Luke Perry and I was just
like I would like do my hair like him
you know like where it was like cool and
high up whatever and then and so that
was like that's how it's gonna be in LA
so I would just like put my put my hair
up and I had that hair dryer and I would
blow it up and then spray you know hair
spray and then I would get to LA and I
was like I'm gonna rock it and I'm gonna
kill it like that and then when I got to
LA
nobody had their hair like that we have
a we have a picture I think side-by-side
of Luke Perry and there's you and it's
funny because now that hair looks so
Jersey I was also right next to Santa
which is so weird look Oh what is that
Santa
I thought you were I thought you were
stuck in a snowdrift
I had a that was that was I had a body
garden I dressed I'm like Santa so
nobody knew that's a woman put it down
you